good afternoon thank you for coming so
my name is Marc seaman and if you want
to know more about me you can go to
blogger play daddy
I'm not gonna tie you with that right
now so there's information there I'm on
Twitter at pleure if that fancy that
catches your fancy what I'm going to try
to do today is to try to answer a couple
of frequently asked questions and it's
going to be two of them and at first
glance if you just list them side by
side you'd probably think that they
don't really seem to be much related to
each other but it turns out that the
answer to one of them will actually also
inform the answer to the other one so
even though there's seemingly unrelated
they actually turn out to be quite
related so I'm gonna do this in over
three acts in the sense that first I'm
going to start with the first frequently
asked question and I'm gonna spend some
time just talking about the context of
it and what would make people ask that
question and I'm not gonna answer the
questions straight away then because
after you know that's the first act that
I'm gonna put it away I'm going to look
at this second frequently asked question
and we'll talk about that and you know
what would make people ask that question
and we'll answer that question and then
it turns out that we in the third act
when we return to the first question we
now have you know an idea about how to
answer that as well because it's
basically informed by the answer for the
for the middle one so the first
frequently asked question that I'm going
to try to answer is how do I combine
dependency injection with a sink and a
weight without leaky abstractions that
is so in order to demonstrate what what
I mean by this you know what what sort
of question this is we need some code to
look at so as always I my favorite
scenario is that of a restaurant
reservation system so I always you know
if I can get away with it try to use
that scenario so you may have seen this
slide before but basically the idea is
that you have you know a online
restaurant in a website and app or
something like that you find your
restaurant you say I would like to make
a reservation for this particular date
you can tell the slide is a couple of
years old now and when you press the
submit button it creates a little JSON
document with that you know data and
then it you know it
sit to a web server somewhere and the
code that we gotta look at is the
server-side part that handles this
incoming request for a reservation and
you know decides what to do with it so
we'll start with the business logic that
domain logic if we will and the and the
first iteration of this code
there will be no async and a wait it's
just going to be straight-up dependency
injection this is just to establish the
baseline sort of you know describe
what's the problem that we're trying to
solve so the core logic is we be modeled
by this method here called try accept
and the idea is that it takes a
reservation is input that's the json
data or the the data for mediation
document that's embedded in this little
object here and then it returns a
notable end
so what's what does that imply well the
int is a reservation ID so if you get an
integer that means you have a
reservation ID that means you have a
reservation you can probably use that
you know integer to go and this you know
use it in other parts of a website or
whatever to modify your reservation or
cancel it stuff like that it's probably
gonna be embedded in a URL somewhere but
if you don't have an integer you don't
have a reservation that means we had to
reject your reservation because we
probably didn't have enough remaining
capacity so that's this is basically how
we communicate back to the corner of
this method you know how you know
whether or not we accepted the
reservation this is the protocol of the
method if we will so this is an instance
method on an object and this could be
part of our domain model and since we're
talking about dependency injection one
thing we can do with this thing is we
can inject an i reservations repository
so so this would be injected via the
constructor and I'm not showing the
constructor here but it just comes with
you the constructor gets saved to
read-only property like this one and
that means we can access it now we can
start to query the repository and say
well give me all the reservations for
this particular date please and now we
have a in a collection of reservations
and now we can do a sum of all the
quantities and say here's a single
number that's the number of reserved
seats we already have for that
particular date and with that number
then we can make a business decision
because if you also
the capacity of the restaurant we can
say well if the capacity is too little
compared to what is being rejected
requested
we'll have to reject the request by
returning null otherwise we can move on
we'll just set and a flag is accepted to
true and then we can call repository but
create with the reservation that creates
a row in the database it returns an
integer that integer gets converted into
an honorable image because that's just
something this sheesh our compiler does
so that's fine that works so that's
pretty straightforward now the call
abstraction right now in the domain
model is the try accept method and we
try to in you know model that explicitly
as an abstraction by having an interface
called Maitre D' a Maitre D' is if you
go into a real restaurant and ask them
whether they have a table you'll be
interacting with someone called the
maitre d or the role called the maitre d
at least in some restaurants so this is
just a little attempt at doing some
domain driven design and using the
ubiquitous language of the organization
stuff like that right so at the boundary
of the system we need to figure out how
do we compose these things so we could
have a post method sitting on a
controller somewhere so you can have
some sort of reservations controller you
can imagine something like that and we
have a post method that receives a
reservation still that JSON object and
it needs to return some sort of action
we solved that's basically just an HTTP
response and again we can use dependency
injection so we could say let's inject
the and I'm a 2d object into this
controller class via the constructor
again I'm not showing the constructor
but the maitre d is available there as a
read-only property so it's pretty simple
we can just call Maitre D' to try except
that returns a novel int we know that
already we can test for null and we can
say well let's return internal server
error if if it's null and otherwise
we'll get the value out of the novel int
and use that to call our little helper
method call okay so internal server
error is a little helper method that we
have that just returns an I action
result and you know don't worry if you
don't know what that interface means but
it's just like this is an implementation
that represents you know 500 internal
server error that HTTP status code and
likewise the ok method is just a little
helper method that returns an
implementation of that interface that
represents 200 ok but you'll notice that
we part of the API is you know contract
is that we return the reservation ID in
this the body of the response in case
where things went well right so this is
just a baseline just to you know get it
up and running the reservations
repository here looks like this so you
might say well ok so we all know that in
reality you know repositories that just
we're just pretending that they're not
databases but really they're just our
basis so we might as well just a call to
the database but if it's a database we
say well but that's you know I oh so
that might be nice to do this with you
know asynchronous because that might be
better it might be more performant may
be more efficient so how do you turn
this into an asynchronous API well you
change the return types into tasks okay
I think this is a leaky abstraction
because you know according to the
dependency inversion principle it's the
client who gets to decide what the
interface looks like and the client is
their Maitre D' class that has this
try/except method it gets to decide what
the what the interface looks like based
on what it needs
it doesn't need these things to be tasks
it went you know it did quite well
just with the non tasks you know that it
had before so we're letting an
implementation detail leak through into
our abstractions which is where we're
not supposed to do that is it a big deal
nah maybe not we can just add you know
async and await various places that
basically solves most of the problems
but we have to change the return type to
tasks of null Burland as well and this
breaks something else because by
changing the return type it no longer
occupy us because the interface didn't
you know define try except like that so
we also have to go and to the I'm a to
the interface
and change the return type here as well
so I think this is even more leaky
because you know sort of I thought I can
sort of accept that a repository
interface everyone knows any repository
so I really just started basis so that's
you know that there a sink okay fair
enough yeah it's not really much of an
abstraction anyway but this is supposed
to be an abstraction it was some domain
model and why does it have to be
asynchronous why why is a business rule
asynchronous that's weird but we have to
you know just accept that that's the
fact and move on so we'll change the
return type here as well and we can go
to the post method now and say well okay
let's fix whatever compiler errors we
have here as well it's just at the awake
keyword change the return type now and
one of the modern web frameworks from
you know that's on net they natively
understand tasks so at this point we're
probably good so this would work and
this this may be better perhaps we don't
know which you should measure but it
might be better it's worth a try right
but I think it's a there are some leaky
abstractions going on here and and again
you say well do we care or is it just a
small price to pay for a lot of you know
better functionality and maybe it's okay
it seems like we have to be a sink all
the way that's nothing new in this you
know you've probably heard this a
thousand times already this is a you
know known best practice about you know
tasks
you know based programming that you have
to be a single the way it's like
dependency injection you have to do di
all the way it seems like there's no
other way you have to do it like that
and whenever people tell me something
like that I'm sort of like oh really
because I like assertions like those
because it just says one counterexample
to prove it wrong and I can come up with
such a counter example and it's not like
you know what I'm just gonna show you
next is necessarily better I think it
would be fairly pragmatic to just use
async and wait like I just showed you
and I might choose that myself
you know from time to time
for pragmatic reasons everyone
understands how that works but it's
always interesting to know that there's
another option because if you know about
options you have you can make better
decisions so I'm not here to sell you on
some sort of exotic way to do things
instead of the way that everyone
understands I'm just here to give you
another option and then you can choose
whether or not you think it's
interesting so I'm not I'm not here to
push anything down your throat all right
so let's pack that aside for a while and
then go to a completely different or
maybe frequently asked question and that
is how do I get the value out of my
monad now I'm not assuming you know what
a mole that is we'll cover that as we go
along but this is a question that seems
to often come up and the short answer is
mu a mu something like that spelled like
this this is a concept in Zen Buddhist
philosophy where it sometimes comes up
and basically means something like null
on you know nothing or you know it's
often interpreted as unasked the
question for a Western perspective of
this you could do worse with your time
and then reading zen and the art of
motorcycle maintenance or gödel Escher
Bach is also a good book there's a -
western books that both talk about this
you know the concepts of MU from the Zen
Buddhist philosophy but basically it
means the question implies some things
are there some implicit assumptions
being made in that question that makes
it actually nonsensical so you can't
really answer the question because it's
you know it's based on some assumptions
fundamental assumptions that are wrong
so this often happens when you you know
when you're beginner with a new piece of
technology it happens to me all the time
so at least to this this situation
called the X Y problem or sort of
questions that are you know based on
this sort of phenomenon this is a
phenomenon that's so common on Stack
Overflow that that's actually a fact for
it
so basically what it means is that often
people would ask you know how you know
they would ask sorry it would ask how do
I do X but really you know if you try to
try to you know dive into you know what
is that you try to do it turns out that
people are trying to do Y and they have
a plan for how they want to achieve that
and that plan involves a series of steps
and they think they know most of the
steps but they stuck on X they can't
figure out how to do X and when you can
unravel all of this stuff and you can
finally you know figure out oh you're
trying to do Y then you shouldn't be
doing X at all you should be doing set
and that will lead you to why there's a
completely different way to think about
some things and that often happens with
monads right so how do I get the value
out of my monad well you don't but
that's not very useful so let's see what
do you do instead let's try to look at
that but first what's a monad I'm not
assuming you know what that is
well a monad is a function you can
flatten okay very helpful
what's a functor so we'll have to start
there the function is a data container
it's not a java container it's not a
dependency injection container you know
it's not a shipping container it's just
a data structure you know that can
contain some sort of value you know
simple values objects whatever so we can
just represent that by a rectangle and
more specifically about a function is
it's a tart a container that supports
what we call a structure preserving map
or a structure preserving projection and
what that means is that we can project
or somehow transform the contents of the
input container into some other type of
contents in a similar-looking container
so this the most easy to understand
example of this is with if you know the
container just contains some values and
that that would be a collection so it
doesn't have to be numbers but a
collection is a container of values not
only collections you know lists
ienumerable of T are a whatever is sort
of collection like so what you can do
with this is you can apply a function to
each element in a collection like adding
one to it and then you get a new
collection you can also transform them
into strings and you get a collection of
strings or you could try to decide
whether they're even or odd and then you
get a collection of boolean values so
notice particularly with the last
example here is that it it's very
specifically ghost false false false
true true false why does it have that
order to it well it's because it's
determined by the order of the input
collection so what we mean by having a
structure preserving projection or a
structure structure preserving map is
exactly that there's a structure to a
collection it has a specific size and it
has to specifically order to the
elements and that structure must be
preserved when we do the projections
which is the case here so that's all
good either other functors so
collections are functors is a very
specific example of a function a
function is a much more broader abstract
term we'll see some other examples later
on and what is what the structure you
know implies for a particular tart a
container depends on that container but
for you know collections it's that it
has it you know that we preserve the
length and the order of things right so
another thing we might notice is that
the output of doing such a projection is
itself a collection it's itself a Tartar
container and that means we can use it
as a second you know as an input for a
new step so we could do something like
this this can often be quite useful
because this enables us to do decoupling
of various different steps so we can
define a step over here and a step over
here and then finally we can sort of
chain them all together some people call
that sort of you know pipeline style of
programming so that's good so often when
we talk about structure preserving maps
you know in in many languages that
operation is actually called map you
know it's it's a function called map or
it's a method called Maps something like
that but it's not in c-sharp you know in
c-sharp you could start with an array
like this one and if you want to do a
projection you use the Select method and
so this adds once to the number you can
call select again to turn things into
strings and you get this array out of it
you probably know this already so I'm
just trying to you know turn you know a
foreign look a foreign sounding word
like functor into something you already
know so this is an example of a functor
it's just like you know you don't see
much microsoft documentation actually
explicitly telling you that collections
and all the link methods like select
that they're based on this concept of a
functor but they are okay so that's one
example
so you'd say it's funny you know no
one's you know seems to be asking the
question how do I get the value out of
my collection everyone understands
that's a nonsensical question so if you
knew that you know the collections if
you knew that that is a functor and it's
also a monad by the way if you knew that
you'd say why would anyone ever ask the
question how do I get the value out of
my monad and it's because you know often
people don't people aren't being told
that you know collections are functions
that collections are monad you know for
example this you sharp documentation
doesn't talk about that so often the
first time you run into the concept of a
monad is in a different context so maybe
you run into the concept of a monad when
you start looking at other types of
containers and here's a you know a
collection of containers that you could
call scaler containers because all of
these contain exactly one value they're
guaranteed to contain a value the value
if you will so we start with an example
like Lacey of T so this is another
generic type is it a functor well we can
make it a function it's not in the base
class library but we could define a
select method for it so we can make it
an extension method that takes a lacy of
TS input and returns a lacy of T we
solve this output and we need a function
you know from t2 to be solved in order
to do that and it's just a one-liner to
implement it you just return a newly a
sea of TV salt and you have a deferred
lambda expressions sitting in there that
just costs the selector on salted value
so it's pretty straightforward and this
preserves the the invariance or this
structure of lacy because if you even if
you do something like this that would be
blocked for blocking for ten seconds you
know this returns immediately it gives
you a lazy of Ind and and it's you
immediately get that lace event and you
can project it you know you can call
select on it to turn it into a lacy of
string and that completes immediately as
well so this preserves the structure of
lacy of end it preserves the invariance
the invariant is that a lacy is lacy
that nothing happens until you force
evaluation by calling value in which
case it blocks for ten seconds so that's
the that's the protocol that's what you
expect
lacy of teen to do and select respects
that you know that behavior it preserves
that behavior and when you call it again
you know you get answered back
immediately
so that select implementation is a
structure preserving map it's just
mapping Lacy's instead of collections so
lazy of T is a functor as well and you
can do the same thing with tasks of T
it's just a little bit of a different
implementation but the idea is the same
you know you can start a task like this
was a minor task of Ind and it completes
immediately and you can project it into
a task of string and it completes
immediately but then if you are weighted
it will probably block you know in this
example it probably will block because
it's you know it's not going to take ten
seconds to reach the third line of code
but if lots of other state things were
happening in between it might actually
return immediately because it's running
in the background thread and if you are
weighted again it returns immediately so
again the Select transformation there
preserves the invariance it it doesn't
change the way that you know a task is
supposed to behave so it's all good now
there could be some discussion of
whether tasks of T really is a functor
monad but it's close enough that we'll
just pretend that it is and move on I
can do all the things we can do with
monads with tasks so well basically so
that's that's pretty good all right so
you'll notice that you could
consistently write X dot select like
this and you know if X is an ienumerable
of T this would work then Y would be you
know if X is either mobile of int that
this would be you know why would be
ienumerable of string but if X is
ienumerable of sorry if X is lazy of int
then Y would be lazy of string and so on
so this works for all the different data
containers we've looked at so far so
there's a common abstraction going on
here and it's actually so well known
that these sheesh our compiler
understands it so we could rewrite the
code like this this is called query
syntax and is it might be a little bit
surprising that we can come up with you
know and say let's make lazy of Tia
functor and now all of a sudden query
syntax is tax is possible even though
you may not think that
was actually built into the language and
the reason for that is because that
query syntax is not built on any
abstraction like ienumerable of T it is
built on the abstraction of a functor so
if you have the right select method this
works all right so so that should cover
what a functor is now we need to figure
out what a monad is so what's a monad
it's a function you can flatten okay
what does that mean
why are functors not flat already what
does a V no means for a function not to
be flat so let's have a look at a couple
of examples so I will start with a
string and you know you can split
strings on certain characters so you
could face I will spit on the comma like
this and you can you know get the array
of strings foo and bar what if you have
an array of strings like that and you
want to project them and you say for
each of those strings I want to split
them into other strings you can do that
but if you do it you get a nested array
so this is an array of a race and maybe
sometimes you need this but often you'd
want a flat one you don't want a nested
array you want a flat array so what can
you do instead well you can call this
method call select many and the reason
why it's called select many is because
it's doing a select but the method that
is doing you know actually producing the
value split produces many values so you
have something that produces many value
and you want to select over that while
flatten as you go so that works and you
get a flat list out of it so select many
if you can if you have a functor and you
can implement flatly select many so that
you have a nested start of container and
you can flatten it with select many if
that's possible then it's a monad this
is what makes you know collections in in
in c-sharp Mona's so select many is
basically the thing that makes the thing
a monad there's nothing not much more to
it than that that's a little bit more
but not much that's the basic concept
all right so let's let's look at another
example then let's look at ask can tasks
being nested so let's see let's say we
have a task of int X and we have another
task of into Y and we want to add them
to
and obviously we can use the async and
await syntax in c-sharp but what if we
wanted to do you know to project them
and use the in this new select method
that we've written so we could do
something like this where we could say X
dot select and that gives us the number
inside of X so we can project over that
but then if we also want to get the
number of you know inside of why we have
to await that so we have to write it and
then you know an asynchronous lambda
expression here and notice the return
type it's a task of tasks of int it is a
nested task how do you get the value out
of that well you can actually go a wait
await Zed I was really surprised when I
saw you know I thought can I do this yes
I can it's all Elaine it looks funny
doesn't it but it's possible it compiles
it works but it's not what you want to
do that's that's odd isn't it so instead
you know you could try to select many
methods you know an extension method for
tasks of T as well I'm not going to show
you how that is implemented it's fairly
straightforward and you could google it
if you want to see how that looks like
but if you do that you can now flatten
as you go and now you have the Z just
being a normal task of end and you could
even do query syntax so you could write
it like this and now there's no more
easing and a wait apart from the await
set towards the end there and this does
what you expect it to do so that's
pretty neat so to summarize so far if
you have a Lacey of string you can get
the value out of that you can access it
by going dot value if you have a task of
string you can get the value out of it
because you can await it and this is not
even limited to C sharp if you in F
sharp you have something called async
which is basically the same as as task
and you can get the string out of an
async of string by calling async dot
run synchronously on on it and even in
Haskell you have those scalar containers
containers that contain just one thing
and you can get the value out of those
containers in most cases so this is a
common thing that you actually see there
is a subset of functors and there's a
subset of monads that guarantee that
there's going to be one value
inside of it and you can get to that
value so if this is your introduction to
monads
I can understand why someone would ask
you know how do I get the value out of
my monad because there are monads where
that question makes sense it makes sense
for all of these but then there are
other monads
where that question starts to you know
be not quite as reasonable so we could
call those semis Gayla containers those
are containers that maybe they contain a
value but they might also not contain a
value there's various ways to go about
that we start with nullable of T because
I think most c-sharp developers probably
know that already so it's also just
called T question mark so is this a
functor well you can create a select
method for it you can write one but
before we do that let's just look at a
little bit of an example here so if we
have you know an ID and honorable ID
like this one just like we had before
with the reservations we we might say
well okay well let's test for null and
if it's not null I know we can I can
pull I can get the value out of out of
the variable there I can go I get our
value and I can pass it in for example
to a customer object that requires you
know customer ID as as input into its
constructor so that's all fine but then
you have this problem you know what do
you you need to also have an else branch
what do you do in the else branch and
this is where people often say well you
know I'm I don't really know exactly
what's the right thing to return so I
don't know what to do I'm throwing
exception this and you know it's just
like it doesn't compose very well
because now if you hide this deep inside
some sort of helper method it's not
really visible to you well you know when
you get to three layers away from it and
you can't remember that that's what you
did and then you get surprised when all
those exceptions get thrown and so on so
it's not really a good way to design
code it'd be much nicer if we could just
sort of you know keep on projecting or
doing structure preserving map inside of
novel of T so it's not awful of T a
functor well it is because we can
implement this neck method on it but
you'll notice one thing though we have
to add those
generic type constraints T must be a
struct t resolve must be a struct and
that is because normal of T itself is
defined in such a way that that only T
must be you know a struct you know a
value typed very type so yes
norm of T is a functor it is a function
on a subset of alternate types that the
subset of value types so we can't do
stuff like this where we say we haven't
you know an honorable end and we can
project that into inaudible boo by
occurring you know I select is even for
example that actually works let's
compile so that's okay but you say well
okay that would be really nice then what
could we do the same thing with our you
know ID what if I have an ala Belen
that's an ID could I just do ID dot
select and then take my integer and
project that into a customer no this
doesn't compile and doesn't compile
because customer is a reference type
it's a class and it doesn't it doesn't
satisfy that type constraint it must be
you know a value type so you sort of
like ah and then you could argue maybe
we could say well but there's always
null but now it has you know a whole
pack of worms that we don't want to get
into right now but their knowledge
really an evil evil language feature
that should never have existed but we
really want to have a better way to
communicate something that composers
that maybe some things are there or
maybe they're not there we'd like
something that like nullable of tea but
just with the type constraint lifted
okay that exists but we have to you know
as an F you know as a as an idea but we
have to implement it ourselves it's not
part of the base class library now it's
called maybe so we could create a class
called maybe of tea some languages also
call it option so if you run into
something called option of tea same
thing this plenty of different ways to
implement a may be cathartic container
I'm just for this purpose I've chosen
the one that's the easiest to explain
this is not necessarily the best
implementation but this is the one
that's the easiest to understand so we
have two class views here we have a flag
called has item and we have you know a
class field called item that is of the
generic type T and then we have two
constructors we have a constructor
takes no arguments and the only thing it
does is that it sets the flag to false
and we have another constructor
overloading
item of the type t makes sure that it's
not null saves the item in the field and
sets the flag to true so that's how we
initialize a maybe of T data container
now this is a functor because we can
write a select method on it so you don't
have to write select methods always as
extension methods this is actually an
instance method on maybe of T so it just
takes an argument that you know function
that we usually call the selector so how
do we implement that well it's pretty
straightforward
you know if has item is true we know
that item is a proper value of the type
T and type T that something of type T is
what we have to use as input for that
selector function that returns a value
of type T result and then we can use
that value of type T result as input
into the maybe of T result constructor
so that's a populated maybe and if we
don't have an item we just return and
mate and you know an empty may be of T
result so this is another structure
preserving map because populated maybes
are always projected into populated
populated maybes empty babies are always
projected into mt emei peas so this
preserves the structure of there may be
no matter whether it's populated or not
so it's a functor yay
we can also creep me on a ride a select
many method that you know behaves
correctly it's basically the same idea
it's just well it's a little different
but it's pretty straightforward
so maybe of T is also a monad yay so
let's just look at a simple example
before we return back to the the async
dependency injection takes an example so
often if you have a string and you want
to pass it into something like an
integer for example you'd have to call
you know into a try pass which is a
horrible you know non composable api
whenever you need to use it you sort of
like aah because you have some code that
flows nicely and all of a sudden you
need to go oh I have to declare you know
an out parameter even though you can now
with news
language features sort of do it in line
but still and then I have to test what
the return value is and if it's true
what do I do and what do I do if it's
false and I know everything is just all
of a sudden very ugly but it turns out
that if you if you wrap that in a little
helper method that returns maybe event
then all will be good because maybes are
composable so you can do this you can
say well if inter try pass returns true
then we will turn a new maybe of int
that contains the integer so that's a
populated maybe and otherwise we'll just
return an empty one and we can do the
same thing for you know all sorts of
other things we want to pass like you
know daytime for example so what you
could do with stuff like this is you
imagine you have you know implementing a
little car rental service and you want
to ask in your you want to ask the
potential customer that you have you
know so from which state do you want to
rent the car so that's what that collect
date method does it asks that question
of the user and then user types in the
answer I want to rent it from you know
the fourth of October and then you get a
string and then you pass that string you
call try pass try pass state with that
string and you're gonna maybe update
time and then you ask the next question
so far how many days three would you
like to rent the car and the user types
in an answer and you get a string back
and you pass that to try pass int and
you get you know a maybe of interact and
then you probably ask some other
questions as well but what you really
want would like to do is once you've
collected all of those answers you'd
like it you like to create a contract so
you say let's project this into a maybe
of contracts and we can use query syntax
to do this so we'll say from D and MD so
D is a date time a date time yeah just a
day time object there or value actually
and then you can go from I in MI and I
is an integer and you can do it you know
if you've collected other things you can
compose those in as well and then
finally you can say select new contract
and then you can just pass the all you
know the value city that you've
collected so far and that produces a
maybe of contract now the way this works
is that if if
all of these maybes are populated then
you'll get a populated maybe of contract
if one of these turn out to be empty the
maybe of contract will be empty as well
so it's sort of like a fast in a fairly
easy way to do some input validation and
projections over those things there are
more sophisticated ways you could do
this but it's actually often gets the
work done pretty done pretty well so
what do we want to do though is you want
to give the put you know your
prospective customer a quote so you say
all right in order to give my customer
quote I need to you know get the
contract out of the maybe because the
contract has a method I can call to
calculate the price so how do I get the
contract out of the maybe and you might
try something like this let's say well
if MC has item I can go MC dot item that
calculate price and now I have my quote
except that this doesn't compile it
doesn't compile because has item and
item are not publicly available well
they are there but they're private and
this is a very deliberate design
decision this is by design you are not
supposed to be doing this you're not
supposed to pull the value out of the
maybe and people try to do this all the
time because unfortunately most you know
maybe implementations that I've seen do
provide a way to do this and it they
ought not to I think it's about design
if you do this so one of the problems
with this if this was possible was what
if MC is empty what's what's going to be
the value of Q then it might be zero now
you have a zero quote in your codebase
now what if someone you know can't
really what if you have a lot of code
and you don't see that and then later on
you just return Q and then you know
sometimes you just return a zero price
so you know you have someone say say
well I would like to rent a Ferrari for
three months what's the price of that
zero rendered cooking you know you don't
want that so um that's not the way to do
it so let's let's try to start over what
what should we do instead well we can
just do projections so what we can do is
we can say let's do it
see that select and then inside of the
select we can just called calculate
price on the contract and that gives us
a maybe of decimal so this is safe this
always works
it works if FC is empty because then
nothing happens and it works if is if FC
is populated because then you know we
actually get a populated maybe of
decimal so basically the answer yeah how
do I get the value out of my monad in
general you don't you inject the desired
behavior into the monad via the
projections that's what's happening here
we're sort of injecting that behavior or
that thing we're interested in
we're just translating maybes will be
staying within the maybe monad so so
that's the partial answer and then you
probably go yeah but you know summary I
need to produce a result because I can't
I can't put a maybe of something on my
use of screen I need to put a quote on
the screen so how do I do that okay fair
enough let's go back to collections for
a moment you know sometimes you also
want to reduce a collection like this to
a single number and maybe if you just
want to add them together there's a
special purpose method for that that
will just return a number so that's fine
but what if you want to do something
else whatever you want to multiply all
the numbers together well there's not a
specialized you know method for that but
you can use a general-purpose one called
aggregate so aggregate enables you to
pass it a lambda expression that will
give you a pair of values and then you
can say for each pair of values x and y
are multiply x with y but you'll notice
that I've I've used an overload here
that takes a seed and I've supplied the
seed of one there's also an over note
that doesn't take a seed and the
difference is that the other overload
that doesn't take a seed doesn't handle
empty collections so if the collection
was empty which this one is not I
realize but if the collection was empty
you know it doesn't know what to do
because it says well I know what to do
if I have two values because I need to
multiply them and if I have one value I
could just return it but if I have zero
values I don't know what to do so bang
you throw some exception but by giving
you a seed to handle the edge case this
is safer this by the way returns zero
because there's a server in that list of
numbers now we can do something similar
with our maybe of T data structure of
data container so I'm not going to call
it accurate I've got a call it match for
various other reasons but the idea is
sort of the same we wanted to return a
value of the type T result even though
this is actually maybe of T and the idea
is in you know similar to this seed
value there's a Nothing value there
which we will use if if the data
container is empty and then there's a
function called just that is a little
projection function and the way we
implement this is just with the ternary
operator we say if we have an item we
can call just on that item and you know
this is a maybe of T so item is of the
type T calling Justin it returns a value
of T for souls so that matches that
compiles and nothing is also of the type
T results so that matches as well so
this is how you can sort of not pull the
value out of them it may be but this is
how you can aggregate the maybe so you
handle all H cases so again this is a
much safer way to go about those things
so so let's go back to how do I combine
the dependency injection with async and
a weight without leaky abstractions so
we remember that we learned this thing
that it needs to be a sink all the way
and the question is okay so is there
another way and there is a classic
maneuver you can do if you're doing you
know functional design you know
functional programming and that is to
move the impure operations to the
boundary of the system you will hear
functional programmers say this all the
time and basically what it means it's
just saying all the all the ugly things
that you know where you communicate with
database oh you paint the UI something
like that
needs to sit in the shell of the
application if you will and then you
have this nice domain logic core in the
middle that doesn't know anything about
this nasty interactions with the outside
world
now this architecture is called port and
adapters or hexagonal architecture or
onion architecture or something like
that it has many names so well known
design principle even in object-oriented
programming so so how do we do that how
do we move the impure operations to the
boundary of the of the system well we
should probably think about
what's an impure operation let's
investigate that through a couple of
examples so in the try/except method
here on the maitre d object there's two
impure operations the first one is read
reservations now there's two ways an
operation can be impure and the first
one is that if it's non-deterministic so
we define determinism in such a way that
if we call the same method with the same
argument it should return the same value
now querying a database doesn't do that
you know you could call read
reservations with the same date multiple
times and each time you do that it would
return a new value it would return a new
collection of reservations and we
understand why that happens that is
because you know the state of the
database changes okay fair enough so you
say but that's still deterministic yeah
but it's just that we don't consider the
state of the database to be part of the
method so therefore we could see that
that to be done non-deterministic and
the other impure operation is repository
create and it does another it performs
another violation of purity and that is
it creates a row in the database so it
produces a side-effect so in order for
in operation to be pure it must you know
have no side-effects and must be
deterministic and that's what we call
referential transparency so we want to
get rid of anything that is not
referring to the transparent that is not
pure and these two things are not pure
so we want to push them away we we don't
want to just not have them we still need
these things to happen but we just want
them to happen in another place which so
we'll try to figure out if we could just
put push them one level out and that's
just to demonstrate that it's possible
to do that right so let's start with the
first one the top one here that's the
easiest one to do so in this case you
will notice we unconditionally call rips
up repository to read reservations so we
might just say I don't want to do that
anymore you know if if anyone wants to
call me then just give me that
information as a method argument problem
solved
that was pretty easy well one problem is
remaining though and that is you know
even though that is
see it causes some other more ugly
things to happen but sometimes things
have to get worse before they can get
better now the problem here is that we
have to change the IMA to the interface
because otherwise it doesn't compile and
you know I talked about before how
implementation details should not have
any influence on how an interface is
defined which is exactly what's
happening now so you definitely say this
is a leaky abstraction this is not good
but just stay with me here because it
turns out in the end it doesn't matter
so just trust me and say well we'll be
editing this abstraction multiple times
but in the end yeah it'll all be
irrelevant so let's see how that that
plays out so if we go back to the post
method on our controller class we'll
need to figure out okay so how do we now
interact with the maitre d object we
have this injected I Maitre D' object
there now first of all we also need to
have a second dependency we need to also
inject the repository into the
controller because what we need to do is
we need to call read reservations and
now we have the reservation so that we
can call try accept and now we can just
proceed as we did before the rest this
is the same as before okay so that works
out pretty well so it's not that wasn't
a difficult change we just move things
around a little bit okay the other one
is a little bit harder how do we get rid
of repositories or create how do we move
that to the outer layer on how to how do
we move that to the caller now this is
more difficult because this is a
conditional thing that happens it only
happens in certain conditions because
there's also this early exit up there
where it returns null where it says well
we can't save anything into the database
because we are already sold out so this
is actually one of the main reasons why
people often use object-oriented
object-oriented often use you know
dependency injection in the first place
because it sort of enables you
dependency injection enables you to
separate your logic your decisions from
the side effects that they will have
because if you had you know instead of
having dependency inject
you could have written directly into the
database here but then you wouldn't have
separated your decision from the
scientific that that decision courses so
by doing the benasi injection you could
say well I'll make a decision and it
looks like it has a side effect but it's
polymorphic so I could actually decide
to not really touch the database but
just have you know but mark or stop or
something like that for test purposes so
this is how often how we would do it an
object-oriented programming but in you
know functional programming for example
this is not good because it's impure and
it destroys the whole you know
referential transparency that functional
programmers really like so we wouldn't
like to do something like that what a
functional programmer would like to do
is to say I will make the decision but
then I will communicate my decision to
the caller and then it's up to the
caller to course the side effect to
happen so how do we communicate the
decision well we sort of know that
already because we have this you know
nullable of int and the protocol was if
you get an integer that means we have a
reservation if you gotten all it means
you had nothing so so we could do
something like that it'd be nice to say
well you know ultimately if we don't
call repository create we don't have any
integer to return though so maybe we
should just return some sort of nullable
of reservation but that's impossible
because you know we can return nullable
of int we could write it like this as
well but in general for novel of T we
have this type constraint that it can
only be a struct so it works for int but
it doesn't work for reservation say so
it'd be much better if we could use a
maybe of T because there's no constraint
on maybe of T right so let's try to do
that as a first step let's just you know
take the novel of int and you know
refactor into a maybe of int and then we
can do an other refactoring after that
so we'll go back to try accept and we'll
change it to return a maybe event and
it's pretty straightforward because it's
self returning no but just return an
empty maybe event here and it down there
towards the bottom instead of returning
you know just in an integer would return
a maybe of Ind
with the idea inside of it so again that
would cause us to change the I'm A to D
into interface definition but again
let's not let's just pretend that that's
not going to matter because it doesn't
if we go back to the post method we now
have the return value is a maybe of Ind
so before we had this little null check
and if we decided that the you know the
ID was not no we could take the value
out of the ID by going ID value and but
this would amount to try to take the
value out of the maybe which we can't by
design we're not supposed to do that so
what do we do instead well we can call
match so I'm just going to call match
here and you can you'll notice it says
return match so the map remember match
is actually a generic narrative type
method so the inferred generic type here
is I actually result so that means I'm
just going to match on whatever is
inside of that maybe and then I'll need
to return you know in all different
cases that I need to cover I need to
return an action result so I'll just say
in the nothing case I'm using named
arguments here in a nothing case I'm
just going to return internal server
error because that's an I action result
that Reese it represents 500 internal
server error and in the just case I'm
just kind of writing a lambda expression
that receives the integer that was
inside the maybe and I'll call okay with
that integer so that looks pretty neat
so this is also why the match method
looks the way that it does instead of
just saying couldn't adjust you know if
I have a maybe event could add couldn't
just you know give you a default value
and then you would give me whatever is
inside and you could give me the default
value if you were empty but the reason
that knot doesn't always work is that
you know for int for example what's the
good default value you know you could
say what's zero but what if zero is
actually a proper ID we don't know so
this is much safer to say well we'll
just you know at the end we know how to
deal with the empty value because that
will be you know an HTTP response that
indicates an error
all right so we're now ready to get rid
of calling repository create when when
if I delete this line of code I no
longer have an ID you know I no longer
have an end so instead of returning a
may be of interest be returning a may be
a reservation but from that it's pretty
much pretty much the same so I'm
communicating my decision the decision
is the same it's a if the maybe is empty
it means I rejected the reservation if
the maybe is populated it means I
accepted the reservation it is now up to
the caller to deal with this this still
means we have to change the I Maitre D'
but never mind that we now have a mate
maybe a reservation but remember maybe
is a functor so what you can do is you
could say let's go MDOT select and then
you know if there's something inside of
that maybe we can go repository create
and again this is safe this is kind of
run if it's populated and if it's not
populated it's just kind of translate an
empty maybe of reservation to an empty
maybe of int well you'd think this is a
maybe event that it translates into but
actually it's a maybe of a task of an
int and that's because of the asynchrony
there it makes things a little bit more
clunky but we can deal with that it's
not a big problem now we sort of have
two monads stacked here because task is
a monad maybe it's a monad we have a
stack of monads but it turns out that
that's a moet as well so all this good
no problem right so we can match on that
you know maybe of task of indus well
it's a it looks a little bit uglier now
but we'll deal with that later on we'll
make it pretty and i'm in five minutes
going back to try except though if an
interesting thing has happened there's a
compiler warning that warning says this
async method lacks await operators oh
yeah it's no longer as asynchronous this
is a completely synchronous thing so
let's get rid of all that asynchronous
crap there you know I really didn't like
that my domain logic had to be
asynchronous because why should it be
but now it's no longer a synchronous all
the rest of the staff can still be
asynchronous will change I am hid what
what does this change entail well we
just have to remove that awake keyword
and that's that all the things that have
to be asynchronous are still the
synchronous the read reservation is
reading from the database still is
synchronous
you're writing to the database with
create still asynchronous business logic
not asynchronous doesn't have to be all
right
come on other things that is that are
interesting yeah you know try accept
this Maitre D' object here no longer use
is the repository so we don't have need
to have that dependency we can just you
know remove it we're pretty close to
having what we would call a pure
function now there's one thing missing
that I'm just gonna skip over but it
actually mutates state it it sets that
is accepted flag so it mutates the state
of reservation this is something that is
fairly easy to refactor into something
that is entirely referentially
transparent but I'm not going to do that
right now because it's not really
important so we just pretend that this
is a pure function because it's good
enough it's close enough to being it's
at least deterministic so going back to
the post method we might actually
observe something interesting you say
why do we have the I Maitre D' interface
why is that an interface Maitre D' is a
pure function out the try/except is a
pure function or pretty close to anyway
why do we have an interface to hide that
away and and you would say maybe you say
well but you know with this because you
know unit testing we need to control how
it behaves yes but now it is entirely
deterministic you can control how it
behaves just by passing the right
arguments to it so there's no reason to
hide it behind an interface so let's
throw away the the dependency and just
create the object we need to know what
the capacity is but apart from that all
is good so coming back to this thing and
the reason why I told you that it's in
the end it doesn't matter is because we
don't need that interface we can delete
it so that's why I wasn't really very
concerned about what happened to that
interface because it's gone
so the only thing I want to do here is
just to clean up that coat a little bit
because it looks it's not that pretty
so through a series of steps that I
don't want to show you you can make it
look much prettier so you might make it
look like this so what we notice here is
that now we basically just have this you
know sort of pipeline way of you know
writing code where we start with one
method call and we just you know project
via select into something else and then
we select many into something else and
then we you know ultimately call match
and that's what we return and so you'll
notice it said select select going on
the select many going on so there's
definitely a monad in action here and
the Mon edits that is the task monad and
inside that task moment is a maybe monad
by the way so it still it you know stack
of monads but but that's okay but I
think the most important thing to
realize here is that what we've done is
exactly what we learned about monads how
do I get the value out of my monad well
you don't you inject the behavior into
the monad so what we've done here is
we're taking our domain logic which is
not aware of any asynchrony at all
because it doesn't need asynchrony and
we've just injected it into an
asynchronous context and it's not aware
that it's running in an asynchronous
context it doesn't need to be aware of
it but all the rest of the things like
reading and writing to databases is done
in a nice asynchronous way so we haven't
compromised any design ideals by doing
it like this so that's basically the
answer to the question how do I combine
dependency injection with a sink and a
weight without leaky abstractions well
you inject the desired behavior into the
async monad or the task monad or
whatever you want to call it because we
know from the general our your question
we had before you know how do I get the
value out of my monad you don't you
inject the desired behavior into the
monad so you could say this is behavior
injection not dependency injection so so
that's what I have for you if you're
interested in learning more block
toploader DK has a lot of content that
relates to this already I have two
articles that I wrote
typically about the code that you have
shown you here today and it's those
articles are written there in my
publication queue they may take a month
or two before they actually get out but
you could subscribe or you could follow
me on twitter and then you'll know what
when they're gonna be out but apart from
that you know that's that's basically
what I'd like to say one thing though is
normally when I give talks like this
I'll have I'd be happy to talk to all
you know people who come up and want to
talk to me afterwards but I actually
have another session at that's for 4/20
so I have to you know package down my
stuff and run to that one but it's an
open panel so you can come and ask me
questions there if you want to so really
I would be delighted to see you but
otherwise you know if you see me in the
floor you know today tomorrow or Friday
you know just come and talk to me and
I'll be happy to talk to you and hear
but if you have questions so you just
want to chat that would be wonderful
but for now I'll let you go and maybe
see some of you in the roommate on level
4 thank you all for coming
[Applause]